- [Mark] All right, Chanel.
- Hi.
- [Mark] Chanel, where
are you from originally?
Where did you grow up?
- [Chanel] I grew up here in LA.
- [Mark] Here in LA.
And did you grow up with
both parents, one parent?
- [Chanel] I grew up with only one parent.
- [Mark] Who was that?
- [Chanel] My mom.
- [Mark] Your mom? And
how was your childhood?
- I was kind of sheltered
and always told to step aside
and it will be done for me.
Until, you know,
I had to grow up,
and it got to the point where
I started to hold grudges,
and, you know, play the blame game and
stuff like that. And I don't know.
- [Mark] Did you have siblings?
- I have one, yes.
- [Mark] And so what age
were you when you discovered
that you were more comfortable as a woman?
- I was 12.
- [Mark] Twelve?
How did that go with your
friends in school, and
stuff like that.
And your parents?
- I hid it until I was put
out of my house at 16 years old.
And then I came out and
I've been out ever since.
And I'm 29 at the moment, I'm sorry.
I'm stuttering.
- [Mark] (indistinct)
So you're living on the street now?
- Yeah.
- [Mark] And how long have
you been out here doing that?
- I've been here for five years.
Every time I try to get
inside I'm always turned down
because they do not take me serious,
I believe. I don't know.
- [Mark] Do you find it's hard
being transgender in society?
Do you have problems getting a job
or getting a break from people?
- It's the stare into my
eyes that they give me
as if I'm a joke, or I'm, you know,
incompetent, I would say.
But you know, it's always been something
that I hold onto my
conscious instead of talking
about it to people.
And I try to, you know, hide it
but it's starting to
hurt me more, and more,
and more as I get older,
and older, and older.
- [Mark] Yeah.
- And, yeah. So that's how that goes.
- [Mark] And stuttering kind of
complicates the issue, right?
- Yeah, it like-
- [Mark] So it's hard
enough being transgender,
And then...
- Right, and I had a-
- [Mark] (indistinct)
- Yeah.
- [Mark] It's a struggle, yeah?
- It kind of is, yeah.
- [Mark] What do you do for money?
What a lot of girls do on the street?
- That does not work
for me anymore because
I find it to where,
I am not attractive to people
after they get into it or they see
that I can't perform
as you know, expected.
So it kind of hinders the
whole confidence that I have
towards doing that.
- [Mark] Why can you not perform?
- Because I'm uncomfortable
in the whole act.
- [Mark] Oh, is that right?
- Right, but it's kind of
grown to be expected of me.
So I show it, but I don't act out on it.
- [Mark] Oh, okay.
- I try to tell people, no, no, no.
And they still, you know, persistently.
So I kind of engage into
it somewhat, but into it,
I try to stop or get it over
with as soon as possible
to please the person and
also keep me at peace.
You know what I mean?
- [Mark] Yeah.
Have you been beaten
up anything like that?
- I've been stabbed here
in my neck right here.
I was stabbed.
Here in my leg I was
stabbed and that's about it,
over the years down here.
- [Mark] And what's your drug out here?
- Crystal.
- [Mark] Crystal?
- And I'm trying to stop it.
I'm trying to stop it
so bad, but then again,
every time I get up, it's in my face.
So I do it.
I tried to cut back on
doing it and I have,
I have. But it's still there, you know?
So I can't get over here just yet.
I'm trying to though. I'm trying to, yeah.
- [Mark] And do you still
have contact with your family?
- My mom is dead.
- [Mark] Oh, really? I'm sorry.
- So no, I don't have contact
with my family anymore.
And everybody else, they kind of hated me.
So no, I don't have contact with them.
- [Mark] Do you have any friends?
- All of them kind of
shown me that they do not
like me neither, but you know
I still try to be as peaceful
and calm and cordial as possible.
But I'm dealing with a lot
of hatred, a lot of it.
- [Chanel] And I get over it
and still continue to talk
to the same people and do the same things.
And it's hurting me. It's hurting me.
- [Mark] It's hard to go through life
without family or friends.
- [Chanel] I try. Huh?
- [Mark] It's hard to go
through life without family,
or friends.
- [Chanel] Right. So I turn
all of the negative, blah, blah
blah, blah, blah, to positive talk.
And I'm kind of being
fake because I hear all
of them talking to me, but
I ain't paying attention
to anything that they're saying, because
deep down inside I'd be
like, okay, this person
is the same person who did this.
So I'm holding grudges
towards them just as I did
towards my mother.
And I'm trying to free
all of it, but it's hard.
It's hard to keep that good faith.
I don't steal.
I don't do any of that to
anybody, but I do kind of
hold that grudge against people.
I don't know how to take the steps towards
gaining a good confidence,
strong confidence and
a good life in my future, I hope I can,
but I'm not...
- [Mark] Do you have any
plans for your future?
- I was planning on
going to Paris to do an
internship there but I would
have to stop doing drugs first
and go into a full type of recovery.
- [Mark] Internship with what?
- Journalism in fashion.
- [Mark] Good for you.
- [Chanel] Yeah.
- [Mark] That could be a nice change.
- [Chanel] That's what I wanted to do.
- [Mark] And getting off meth
would be a good change too.
- [Chanel] Yeah, it would
and I'm trying my best.
I'm trying my best.
- [Mark] All right.
Chanel, thank you so
much for talking to me.
- Thank you.
- [Mark] And good luck with everything.
- I thank you so much, I hope so too. Bye.